dans son petit atelier niché au coeur de
la vallée de chevreuse et maccoll
nettoie d'un passionné par le vert
depuis tout petit c'est dans l'univers
du vitrail qu'elle a décidé de
s'installer être restaurateur c'est
transmettre aux générations futures on a
un rôle un peu de passeurs
de notre patrimoine
ontarien principalement pour les
mondiaux masters qui avaient misé
en france et en europe par exemple le
j'interviens pour la ville de paris on a
tous lendemain une partie de l'entretien
des édifices civils et religieux et et
on intervient sur la cathédrale de
chartres notamment emma fait partie de
la quinzaine de restaurateurs de vitraux
habilités à intervenir pour les
monuments historiques et les musées de
france un savoir faire qui lui a valu
d'être rappelé en urgence après l'
incendie de notre dame de paris pour
mettre en sécurité les vitraux son
atelier l'atelier mur annese choisi par
l'établissement public chargé de la
conservation et de la restauration de la
cathédrale fait maintenant partie des
huit ateliers sélectionnées par appel
d'offres pour procéder à leur
restauration nous avons des baies hot du
coeur au niveau du transept cap bep de
notre dame est à peu près 45 panneaux
par par ferrières les archanges qui sont
situées sous les personnages bibliques
donc sur un fond bleu assez
assez présent sur l'ensemble de la
verrière encrassé et noirci il n'avait
jamais été véritablement nettoyer les
vitres ont beaucoup souffert déjà en
amont avant l'incendié en lui-même
par la pollution il ya eu un gros
encrassement
l'intérieur et puis après ça a été
accentuée par parler d'eux les fumeurs
là du coup je suis en train d'enlever
toute la poussière accumulée sur sur ce
vitrail et ensuite on va vraiment
attaqué en fait tout à l'arrière on a
des gros dépôts on aperçoit la et qui
obscurcissent pas mal les panneaux est
assez fier de participer à ce chantier
qui est quand même un chantier
exceptionnel à une échelle une échelle
très près la race et c'est très
impressionnant un travail de fourmi qui
demande patience et méticulosité
objectif que les vitraux soit prêt pour
la réouverture de la cathédrale en 2024